so how would you feel  to the mountains for Christmas with  grace she really wants to get to know  you guys that's our mom's hat ah  okay I don't want to leave you here with  the kids if you're not feeling up talk  yeah I'm feeling fine it was my idea and  it's a couple days I can do a couple  days  okay guys I'm off fun what is that  what surprised everyone committed  suicide ease of her repent and you will  find salvage things are very  uncomfortable between us we're stuck in  a house together what is this a pirate  oh where are my things  it makes no sense  what I heard something hello  did you do that we didn't do anything  we're leaving what are you talking about  look outside we're stuck here  okay  trust me  you have nothing to be scared about  you  you